uh oh you know what let's do this i'm
gonna put
this furious trumpus jimmy from philly
we agreed he would call in
because he has some insane situation
going on that i want to hear about i
hope we're able to talk about it
rationally
jimmy are you there my friend yeah i'm
here
okay so i want jimmy
let me see if i can set this up jimmy
and then i'll start getting
your input on it jimmy contacted me
saying he had
a gofundme and i
looked at it and it looks as though
jimmy complained to me that someone
stole his trump lawn signs but then in
the gofundme it looks like jimmy's
raising money for legal fees because he
got arrested so
jimmy explain what happened okay
so i'm sitting uh two day the day before
someone stole
two of my trump signs okay i reported
them that morning
someone stole another one reported that
one too okay now hold on jimmy jimmy
jimmy i want
if we're going to do this we got to make
sure we have the details clear so
i want to make sure we understand you
you awoke and looked outside
your trump signs were gone and you
called the police and said i'm reporting
the theft of my trump sign is that what
you mean by i reported it
yes okay good got it yeah they came out
the first time and then when i called
the next morning and said i will just
add it to the report got it yeah thanks
officer but anyway
so i sit out there and i have a few
drinks and i'm basically guarding my
signs you know and uh
four black young black men and i never
felt menaced
david they were having a ball they were
gleeful
they ran onto the lawn so quickly i
didn't even have time to stand up
they grabbed four signs they ran into
their car and they drove around the
block three times
fyd f trump then they're stopped at the
light
and i ran after them to stop the car
get my you know stuff i was out of my
mind you know
so some trump payton person
didn't take a video of that but they
took a video of me running down the
street like a lunatic
okay so jimmy let's pause let's pause
because i don't want to miss a second of
this idiocy and i want my audience to
fully understand it
this is now separate from the initial
the incidents you reported you're out on
your lawn having a beer
and four men who you believe to be black
and find their race relevant
they steal your lawn signs and drive
away but then they're circling the block
is that correct
yes the circling of the block screaming
f whitey
uh f trump okay and then don't believe
them
and they were black i got eyes uh pretty
good vision
i do wear glasses but and then jimmy and
then so you
run after the car you run out into the
street and run after the car
yeah yeah okay and obviously a car is
faster
obviously a car is faster than a person
so does the car out there
they were stopped at the light okay less
than half a block away
okay okay so i went after the car they
get out of the car now they could have
beat me up
okay but they had never had the
intention they were just
20 some some 20 somethings out
just trying to mess with mess with kid
you know they were like laughing and
they chased me back to my house
right so the cops come the cop says to
me listen jimmy
he says i understand about the trump
signs
you're allowed to be drunk on your
property but the moment
you step off your property you're
publicly drunk and i have to arrest
yourself
okay now jimmy hold on i want to commend
you now that you're speaking more
quietly
your audio is coming through so much
more nicely so let's keep the quiet
voice now here's the one detail you
skipped over
you claim that these four men chased you
back to your house
and then the police show up
at what were these four guys doing then
did they run away
while they had left i mean i guess the
cops came maybe five minutes later
okay and the cop says you can be drunk
on your property but once you leave your
property it's public intoxication
yes and he said and because i have a
video he said if i didn't have the video
i wouldn't lock you up he's like but i
have a video
it's you and uh you gotta go so i put my
hands behind my back i give no static
so you were you were arrested for public
and toxic
if i understand correctly jeremy hold on
correct you were arrested
for public intoxication for chasing a
car
full of men who had stolen your trump
sign
in your neighborhood correct okay
correct so it gets better so they bring
me to the police station
and the intake top says look i blow the
breath a lot they said you're not that
big
usually when we get a call for the
public dunking we're expecting
holy hell but we're not going to cuff
you to the chair
don't act up which i didn't he hands me
my cell phone and he says
call a friend as soon as they come you
can go i call three people nobody's
answering he says look
you can sit there for an hour and call
just keep calling people yeah so i call
my old boss recently
jimmy i'll be there in 12 minutes one
hour goes by
two hours goes by three hours goes by i
scream under the cell door
the protocol is to test me you can't
hold me here all night just because you
want to
so they come and test me and they say
you're just blowing under the legal
limit
we're gonna give you a ride home gee
thanks
so i called my lawyer and he said jimmy
they got you
basically it's an unfortunate situation
uh you know he said
i could probably bring into the
mitigation that signs were stolen before
and you know that they you know were
riding around the block pointing you
you weren't thinking correctly you said
but by law yeah you are getting he said
and he said jimmy i'm going to probably
hit you for 1500 you're probably going
to lose then you're going to probably
have to pay the fine too
right and the sergeant assad stole me
said look jimmy the finest 2 300.
he would go for me you know
because initially i was trying to raise
1500 right okay jimmy
but we're just all i need to kind of
manage this a little bit because it's
we're just
all over the place so as it stands right
now
it it sounds like you're saying you're
not going to hire a lawyer
for 1500 because public intoxication
it's not like you're going to go to
prison or jail you're going to owe a few
hundred bucks is that right
right it's a fine of probably two to
three hundred and let's face it david
fifteen number four lawyer who's telling
me i'll probably lose and this lawyer
has never lost a case for me i mean he's
a bad boy
i mean i i've protested in front of
lawyers
banks or banks i've been arrested for
protesting many times i beat the case
every time
but anyway i'd have to throw 15 in him
probably two or three more for a fine
and lose a day's work
right so the smart thing to do is take
it on the chin
and pay the fun do you think the smarter
thing to do would be
not to drunkenly chase after people in
your neighborhood is that smarter
well the smart thing to do would be not
to go on my lawn and steal my property
right but i'm talking about you can only
control your actions right you can't
control those of others
this is true this is true but hear me
out david no but here hold on jimmy i i
want to keep get keep on the core part
so in our conversations you've revealed
that
you were previously arrested for
domestic violence which is why you don't
see your daughter regularly and now
you've been arrested for public
that's not true i don't see my daughter
regularly because her mother has
poisoned
her against me i've seen my daughter for
years after that incident took her to uh
every amusement park under the sun
bought the uh you know you buy the 100
wristband at six flags and you go on the
ride twice and
all that five hundred dollars i would
spend every time i took the kid out
every sunday
all right jimmy listen uh
yeah i mean you know that you and i
don't agree on politics i reject your
your
racist xenophobic homophobic views but
it sounds like you're in a tough spot so
i'm sorry to hear that
david david i'm far from a racist and
let me explain to you how bad this
country's gone and it's a very short
story
no no but jimmy jimmy i think you you've
i've i told you i would go to you if you
called in
we've given you about twice the time
most callers get so let's put a pause on
it there
i think the audience gets the story now
and i think we've done enough for one
day jimmy
okay but i just want to tell you that
the hard baster is
killing you david i don't know what that
is is that a relative of yours
he's telling you pac-man fever
david pakman power enema
david he's killing you he's killing you
this is your
friend and some of you
some of your uh leftist compatriots come
on to my channel and they are respectful
oh my god all right there's just i have
to cut it because there's just no ending
it
okay um we're gonna go to a quick break
and then right back to the phone line so
don't hang up if you are holding